new burst of grief in Ukraine's
increasingly Under Fire Capital
relatives mourn not at gravesides but by
the newly covered bodies of the Dead a
nine-year-old girl her mother and
another woman killed on children's day
they'd run to a bomb shelter under this
hospital but found the door locked they
were still waiting to get in when debris
fell from an overhead missile
interception yarislav ryajuk's wife of
17 years Natalya was one of the women
killed
my wife is lying there dead just because
the guard didn't open the door they
asked me to go around the building and
wake him up I ran but then the explosion
happened shattered glass started falling
and I knew I had to run back when I
returned it was over there was a lot of
blood women children
visiting the scene said an investigation
was underway Ukraine says 10 ballistic
and three cruise missiles were launched
on Kiev all of them intercepted but
interceptions can themselves have fatal
consequences dash cam footage released
on Thursday showed just how close an
escape driver is in the capital had on
Monday when part of a missile came down
on a road
Russian civilians too have been
describing Their Fear after early
morning strikes On the Border Town of
chebekino in the Belgard region in video
broadcast on Russian State television
people said they were forced to stay in
place for hours several residents
reportedly injured before evacuations
could begin
it was terrible shelling just terrible
they broke the windows they broke our
windows we were very scared earlier
soul-styled anti-kremlin Russian
Fighters based in Ukraine released video
in which they said they were preparing
an incursion into Russia
named Fighters saying the forces would
soon be in chebekino and blaming the
Russian military for shelling the area
drone video released by the freedom of
Russian Legion purported to show Russian
military targets being destroyed
Russia's defense Ministry said it had
repelled an attempted raid
more than 30 Ukrainian terrorists four
armored combat Vehicles one grad
multiple missile launcher and one pickup
truck were destroyed in the Border area
on the Ukrainian side
Ukraine has been promising to launch its
counter-offensive for some time now
already the intensity of the fighting in
this war seems to be increasing Harry
Fawcett Al Jazeera